today we'll be talking about model based
RL for multitask learning and so far
we've talked all the oral that we've
talked about is model free and so we'll
be talking about a different class of
approaches that you leverage models
so um some Logistics we sent out the
mid-quarter survey this is to kind of
supplement the high resolution feedback
that we've already been doing but we'd
really value your feedback the feedback
that we've used in previous quarters
kind of helped us improve the course
it's one of the reasons why we're using
pytorch for the assignments this quarter
um among a number of other things
also homework 3 is out and it's due uh
Wednesday next week
um and then the optional homework four
will also go out next week on Wednesday
great so today I'll briefly recap goal
condition Daryl and relabeling this is
the topic of homework three and so we'll
just do a quick recap of that
to get on the same page and then we'll
transition into model based RL
uh and we'll talk about how model-based
RL can be used for multitask learning
um and then we'll also be talking about
model based RL when you have image
observations or other like high
dimensional inputs because that's
introduced an additional challenge in
the model based setting
and then the goals of the lecture will
be to understand how to use and
Implement Implement some simple model
based RL algorithms
to understand how model based RL can be
used for multitask reinforcement
learning and some of the challenges and
strategies for performing model based RL
in higher dimensional spaces
cool um so to recap the lecture on
Wednesday last week and Monday this week
um we introduced kind of model free
reinforcement learning methods such as
policy gradients and Q learning and we
saw this sort of uh kind of anatomy of
an algorithm where you collect data by
for example running your policy then you
fit them all some form of model to
estimate return and then you use that to
improve your policy
um and we saw a couple different cases
of actually instantiating this kind of
framework so for example you could try
to estimate the return directly by just
summing your Rewards
or you could actually fit a Critic Hue
function to try to estimate your
expected return from your future state
from your current state
and then once you have this estimate of
your
future return you can use that to either
update your policy using a policy
gradient directly or by uh
taking the actions that will maximize
your Q value
now in this lecture we're going to be
focusing on model based RL methods which
will actually incorporate a different
kind of model in order to improve the
policy
um previously we also talked about what
a reinforcement learning task is a task
essentially corresponds to a markup
decision process which has a state space
and action space initial State
distribution Dynamics and reward and
different aspects of this problem
um can
essentially correspond to different
tasks some tasks might share a lot of
aspects of these and only have one thing
varying
alternatively we could view this as
having a task identifier be part of the
state
um where as far as your original state
space and Zi is your task identifier
um
in this case your policy
um you can view your policy is
essentially conditioning on your task
identifier
um and likewise also your key function
conditioning on the task identifier
zi could be a number of different things
it could be a one hot task ID it could
be a natural language description of the
task it could also be a desired goal
State like a particular state that you
want to be able to reach and in this
case this is what's referred to as gold
conditioned RL which is a special case
of multitask reinforcement learning
great so
um we also looked at uh this example
where we have one hit a puck into a goal
or you either want to get hit into a
goal or pass it to our um to our
teammate so task one is passing and task
two is shooting goals
and if you accidentally perform a good
pass when you're trying to shoot a goal
then you can actually store that
experience as normal but also
pretend that that was actually what
you're trying to do and
um and relabel that experience with the
task identifier of
um
of uh of actually a task one I think
that this should be that's a typo
relabel it with task one and store it in
your buffer
um so this is referred to as data
sharing and multitask Ro
and also known as hindsight relabeling
where we're going to be kind of in
hindsight relabeling what the tasks that
we were actually doing in order to
improve
learning for these different tasks
or how did that experience replay
great um so we saw this algorithm which
you're going to be implementing in
homework 3. where you collect data using
some policy
then you store that data in your replay
buffer
and then when you want to perform
hindsight relabeling you
take your experience in DK and you
relabel the
last state when you choose what the goal
is or what the task identifier is for
that particular transition or for that
particular trajectory you will set the
goal to be the last state in that
trajectory
um
great and so you can see that right here
where
um you have your experience and then
your goal is the third element of that
Tuple which is uh story St instead of
the original goal that you were trying
to accomplish
then you'll store that relabel data in
the replay buffer and then update your
policy using the data that you have so
far
um and you'll iterate and so forth
there's also other relabeling strategies
rather than just relabeling the goal as
the last state you could also really
choose for example any state in the
trajectory
um or you could pick a random State as
well
and in your homework you'll explore
these different strategies
okay and then the results of this
procedure is that this can help with
exploration because if we incidentally
collected data that's useful for other
tasks we are sharing that data across
the tasks
um so you don't have to like explore
every single task independently
cool um so that was a brief recap of of
little condition RL any questions on
that before we get to model based RL
okay
so um in Mobile stream enforcement
learning really the main idea here is to
learn a model of the environment
and
what I mean by that is we're actually
going to try to learn what the next
state is given the current state in
action we're going to actually learn how
to predict the future basically
and uh this can be useful because if you
can learn a model like this it often
leads to better data efficiency because
then you can query that model rather
than the true environment
um and you can also reuse this model
across different tasks
and so at a high level the way that this
works is you
try to estimate the distribution of the
next state given the current state in
action with some function f
and then once you have this model you
use it to plan actions to take
um that's kind of the high level just
about how it works we try to fit a model
we try to learn how to predict the
future and then we use that model when
um when choosing actions
it's also worth mentioning that instead
of
um plan the actions you could also use
it to fit a policy
in this lecture we're going to be
focusing on using it for planning
um but if you're interested in learning
more about how to optimize policies with
it I'm happy to discuss that in office
hours or something
and now one of the things that's nice
about this is how do you go about for uh
learning this model um you can learn it
just with supervised learning where for
example you're trying to minimize
something like the mean squared error
between your model's predictions and the
true next state
um and supervised learning is pretty
nice uh we know how to do it pretty well
okay
um like I mentioned you can also use it
to optimize a policy
so what does this have to do with
multitask reinforcement learning
one thing that's really nice about model
based RL is that there is a special
class of multitask URL problems that it
is actually quite amenable to
which is that in the general case we
consider tasks that look like this
but in many situations only the reward
function is going to be varying across
tasks and you'll have the same state
space action space and Dynamics
and really today we're going to be
focusing on this special case where each
task corresponds to something like this
or you notice that only the reward is
indexed by I
and all the other aspects of the task
are shared across all of the tasks
so we can think about a few examples so
maybe in robotics the laws of physics
are constant
um
across different parts of the world but
you might want your robot to perform
different objectives uh like
um doing laundry for you cooking for you
that sort of stuff
and so in this case these different
tasks correspond to this special case
where only the reward is changing and
everything else is constant
another example is maybe we want a kind
of virtual assistant or some form of
dialogue system
where the user and the language that
it's speaking in are constant across the
tasks uh but you have different
objectives so maybe in some cases you
want it to order food for you maybe you
want to provide emotional support in
this case also the Dynamics and the
state space and everything are the same
but the reward function like ultimately
what you want it to accomplish for you
is different
yeah so if you're a different tests
correspond to different robots
um
if those robots have different
embodiments or something like that then
then these things would would vary
across tasks yeah
cool and then in autonomous driving
um another example is that usually the
rules of the road are relatively
constant if you're in the same country
for example but different preferences
users have different preferences
um some people maybe want you to drive
fast some people might want you to drive
smoothly
um maybe you also want to get to
different destinations
and so in this case again generally the
Dynamics are the same
um assuming that it's the same car as
well but what's differing is the
objective that you're trying to
accomplish
so one thing that you can notice here is
that in this case
where this is our task our tasks look
like this
um the model is the same across all the
tasks and so estimating the model is
actually a single task learning problem
and what is the multi where the
multitask part comes in is actually how
you use that model to plan actions
and this is pretty nice because uh
learning the model
um are generally learning about an mdp
can be challenging and if it's
a single task learning problem then it's
going to be easier than a multitask
problem
so we can fit a single model for all of
the tasks and then just plan to
accomplish different tasks using that
single model
okay so how do we actually use a model
to plan
um the
just the approach that we'll consider is
to optimize
your actions using the model and we have
this objective right here which is to
maximize our sum of Rewards
um and we're performing this
maximization over our sequence of
actions
so we're essentially trying to find a
course of action
that will lead to maximal reward
and this optimization is referred to
more colloquially as planning in the
sense that you're essentially planning
what you want to do in order to
accomplish an objective
yeah
yeah that's a great question so the
question was do we know the form of the
reward function we're learning the
Dynamics do we know the form of the
reward function
um in some cases yes in some cases no
I'll talk about the two cases after we
go through the the process you can
assume that we know in all these cases
you could assume that we know the
functional form of R
um that we can essentially evaluate our
given a state in action but we might
have known it or we might have learned
it
yeah great question so do I mean open
loop planning or closed loop planning
um we're going to start with open loop
planning and then we'll we'll talk about
closed loop planning after that
um and it's a pretty important
distinction and it'll come up later
cool so
how do we actually go about optimizing
this objective
so we have our model and you can think
of
you can essentially like roll out your
model
um kind of apply it iteratively from
your current state to given your actions
to kind of predict what the future will
look like in a computation graph like
this
and then we can also measure the reward
given the state in action at each time
step
uh and so
if we want to optimize the actions that
maximize rewards and we know our model
then what we can do is we can
essentially back propagate from the
rewards into the actions
and essentially run this computation
graph compute the gradients of the
rewards with respect to the actions
using your Dynamics model
and so note here that we're going to be
doing gradient descent but instead of
doing great set on some parameters we're
going to be doing gradient descent on
our actions
um and so uh explicitly what this will
look like
is
first we're going to run some policy to
collect some data
this could be a random policy for
example
then we'll fit a model using the data
from this policy
this is just done with supervised
learning
and then we'll back propagate from the
reward through the model into the
actions to choose actions
and this last step here Will
essentially initial pick an initial set
of actions uh that are sampled randomly
and then run gradient descent by
iteratively Computing the gradient of
the action of the reward with respect to
the action applying that gradient to the
action and then repeating
because we have a model if the model is
accurate we can actually Leverage The
Great like Leverage that functional form
of that model to back propagate through
it and this is going to be better than
something like q-learning if your model
is accurate because the model is not
only going to tell you what the feature
will look like it's also going to tell
you like the gradients of Your Action
how your action affects your state
basically yeah
um
yeah so the question is what if your
actions are discreet rather than
continuous
um in that case I probably wouldn't use
back propagation and on the approach 1B
we'll see something that would work for
discrete actions
um
you can also consider trying to optimize
with respect to some sampling
distribution and kind of use a gradient
estimator to differentiate through the
sampling process from that discrete
distribution but in general that sort of
gradient estimation is prone to errors
yeah so the question is does this only
give you actions where there's sorry
does it only give you gradients with
respect to actions in your data set
um and the answer is is
um no you can't actually get gradients
for actions that aren't in your data set
and essentially what this uh third
process corresponds to is
um first you pick some
uh initial
a one two eight
this could be like like in neural
networks you randomly initialize your
parameters you're going to randomly
initialize your action sequence and then
you can basically compute
um the gradient of your sum of rewards
with respect to this action sequence
and the way that you can compute this is
basically with the chain rule where you
use Dr D I'm assuming that the reward
only depends on state for now drds and
then DS
I guess this is technically drd um
like all of the time steps uh S1 to H
and then you're going to take the
gradient of this with respect to your
actions
um
one to each and this is going to like
this gradient is what's going to be
using your Dynamics model but
essentially back propagating through
that model this does assume that your
model the model that you learn is
differentiable uh fortunately things
like neural networks you can
differentiate through them
um and so you're gonna be
differentiating into the inputs of the
model not into the parameters of the
model
and then you'll
for completeness uh you'll then apply
this gradient
um to update
uh so it'll be one my uh
minus the gradient something like that
and you'll have some learning rate
yeah you want to apply another video
I think these actions or yeah so then
when you want to then kind of uh iterate
this process you will need to then run
these actions through your model again
and back propagate into them again
um and the way the reason why this works
is that you can you can evaluate your
model on lots of different action
sequences not just the ones in the data
yeah
yeah
um
foreign
yeah so the question is when you're
fitting your model it uh if there's a
lot of dimensions of the state that have
irrelevant information information
that's irrelevant to the reward will
this word like the L2 loss Will that
will that cause problems essentially and
um the model will actually have to model
everything in the state and if there's
only a very tiny part of the state that
is relevant towards the reward then this
approach might struggle if it doesn't
model that part of the state well
um and so that is one of the downsides
of model-based approaches is that there
is this mismatch between the goal of
fitting a model and the goal of
um kind of fitting the return especially
if there's large parts of the state that
aren't relevant to the return
cool um so gradient-based optimization
is the first way that we can go about
optimizing for
our actions for go about planning
essentially
um the second way that we can go about
this is with the sampling based
optimization
um and we're going to be still trying to
optimize the same objective
but instead of uh using gradients we're
going to use a gradient free operation
or optimization that tries to
essentially just sample options and
choose the actions that perform the best
so the algorithm itself will look
basically the same as before we're going
to run some policy use a model to fit
the to fit the Dynamics from that data
and then we're going to perform a
sampling based optimization to choose
actions
um what do different sampling based
optimizations look like
the dumbest approach is to basically
just randomly sample and pick the best
one
so what this looks like is we'll denote
our action sequence with capital A just
for uh brevity
and in kind of really the simplest
approach that we could do here is we
guess and check so we'll sample a bunch
of different action sequences
like maybe a thousand or ten thousand or
something from some distribution like a
uniform distribution
and then we'll just choose the action
sequence that maximizes reward
um
this is maybe uh not the smartest way to
optimize the objective but if you
actually paralyze the sampling process
and the evaluation process it can
actually be super fast which is nice it
also works with discrete actions
um
and uh yeah
of course this also has limitations
which is that if your sampling
distribution is very broad or isn't very
good
then your
um
then you're the action sequence that
you'll get also won't be very good
um so this is the kind of the
optimization for choosing actions with
respect to our model uh and we're gonna
we're going to be learning the model and
then after we learn the model we're
going to be using this to plan actions
with respect to that model
yeah the model is still is still
optimized with gradient effect
um now this is kind of uh not the
smartest approach um and uh it's
referred to as random shooting because
you are kind of essentially shooting out
different action sequences at random and
trying to pick the one that works the
best
uh can we improve this distribution
um one version that of this algorithm
that is slightly better is instead of
just taking a single distribution and
sampling from it is we could actually
iteratively improve that distribution
um and this is what's known as the cross
entropy method so we sample first start
by sampling action sequences from some
distribution P
um this could initially be the uniform
distribution
then we evaluate the sum of rewards for
each of those action sequences we see
how well they did
and then what we'll do is we'll pick the
action sequences that had the best
reward
and we'll refit a distribution to those
best action sequences
and then we can essentially repeat this
process and then resample from that
improved distribution basically from the
distribution that did the best
um and then kind of iteratively refine
our distribution that we're sampling
from
um
and uh kind of in terms of some of the
details uh I think that this process is
fairly straightforward you evaluate each
of your action sequences and you pick
the ones that are the best or the elites
um in terms of fitting a distribution to
this you could fit a gaussian
distribution to it you could fit
um like a Multiverse sorry a um a
mixture of options to those action
sequences or something else
um this is probably the most complicated
step but uh once you do this then you
just resample from that distribution and
repeat
um there are also more advanced methods
for sampling based optimization
um there's what's called uh kind of
evolutionary methods and uh
method called CM cmaes uh
but it turns out that actually in a lot
of cases these two approaches aren't
actually as bad as you might think
yeah
kind of like
maintains the probability
yeah so you do need to get good coverage
from your initial distribution and the
question was like do you get stuck in a
local Optimum potentially
um if you have good coverage in this
initial distribution and your
optimization landscape is somewhat
smooth then it should uh it shouldn't
get stuck but if for example
um
say uh say you like sample from this
distribution and like right here is like
really good but everything around that
is not very good and you like draw some
samples that don't include that region
right there then you are going to miss
this
um because maybe there's a spot over
here that's like a little bit better
um
and uh in that case you will not hit the
global Optimum because you didn't like
because you have this pretty non-smooth
landscape if you have a smoother
landscape where like
uh this part is like is clearly better
than other parts of the landscape then
it'll be easier for it to optimize
that's also true for gradient-based
methods as well
um gradient-based methods can also they
are a local optimization and if the
gradient
um for example points them towards an
Optimum that isn't as good as another
one then they'll also get stuck
so to recap the way that we kind of
iteratively resample as we
sample at random to start and then we
pick some subset of those samples that
are the best we refit a distribution to
those samples and then resample from
that distribution
foreign
so for sampling based optimization uh
one of the benefits of this is that it's
pretty fast especially if you paralyze
things the only thing that's iterative
is that like different iterations of the
Cross entropy method
whereas gradient descent is like fully
sequential and you can't paralyze it
easily
um it's also super simple so it's pretty
easy to implement and you don't need to
worry about you don't need to worry as
much about like the initialization for
example
uh the downside is that it doesn't scale
to high Dimensions
um fortunately action sequences are
usually much lower dimensional than say
like neural network parameters
so this is one reason why we would use
this kind of optimization for Action
sequences
and we definitely wouldn't use it for
neural network parameters although
actually some people have found it to
sometimes work for neural network
parameters
um this includes in terms of
dimensionality this includes both the
Horizon and your action dimensionality
and that's because when you do this
optimization you're optimizing over the
entire sequence of actions and not just
like the first action for example it is
important to optimize over the entire
sequence
so that you actually consider like
long-term outcomes
cool so
um in terms of the the algorithm
they're kind of kind of jumping back up
um we're again going to be kind of
collecting some data fitting a model and
then improving or
optimizing for Action sequences with
respect to that model for example using
random shooting or cross entropy method
or using a gradient-based optimization
cool
so that was essentially version one and
really one of the basics of model based
RL
now how can this approach fail
so say for example you are here and you
want to get up to be like as high as
possible you want to get to the kind of
top of
um
you want to be hired so that you can see
further or something like that
um you're first going to run some policy
and you'll collect data that looks maybe
something like this because it's some
random policy
then you'll learn a model to fit this
data that tells you what
um
essentially what will happen if you go
in certain directions
and one thing that you might learn from
this data is that
if you go towards the right then you can
go higher because in this kind of region
where you collected data you always saw
that if you went right you got to a
higher elevation
and then now you're going to optimize
for actions or plan actions so that you
maximize reward and so if you want to go
higher you'll learn that you should go
to the right
uh and then now one thing you might
notice here is that if you do that then
you'll uh kind of keep on going right
and and fall off the cliff
now uh what went wrong here
so
the issue here is that there's this data
distribution mismatch between the data
that you fit the model on and the data
that you're using the model on that
you're evaluating the model on
and essentially the distribution from
the initial policy on the left is
different from the state distribution
that you're actually evaluating your
your final policy on
um and your model didn't see any data
falling off the cliff and so it doesn't
know how to avoid falling off the cliff
cool
um so a thought exercise for all of you
how might you go about alleviating this
issue
yeah so the one thing that you could do
is in your initial policy try to explore
as much as possible so that you can see
a much broader distribution and so that
you can cover more that's a good idea
yeah
foreign
[Music]
yeah so when you optimize for actions
you could optimize not just for
maximizing reward but also staying close
to your initial policy
other thoughts
sorry can you repeat that
um with many iterations would you
recognize this through data distribution
yeah so the um I think that you could
essentially view this as a suggestion
for how to alleviate the problem which
is that
um one thing that you could do is
kind of collect data using your model
and then add that data to your buffer of
data and refit your model using the data
that you collected
by planning
so that's the third thing that we can do
any other ideas
okay so those are good suggestions the
first suggestion was collect more
diverse data at the beating the second
was to try to stay close to your initial
policy and then the third was to
recollect data
um
I'm going to kind of outline the last
one which is that when you
kind of start planning with your model
you can then
um execute those planned actions and
append those that data to your data set
and then refit your model with that data
set
and this is a nice approach because it
means that you can explicitly in a very
targeted way try to explore
um to Regions where you think that there
might be reward because you're planning
to try to accompl to reach those regions
um and learn a good model in the parts
of the state space where you think that
there might be a good reward
cool
okay
um so then if you do this uh if you
execute your planned actions you'll
collect data that looks like this so
you'll learn what it's like to fall off
cliffs and then you'll learn to kind of
eventually
go to the top and then stop
um because your model will learn that if
you keep on going from that point uh you
will no longer go higher
yeah yeah
you mean does it give you an estimate
for a bad estimate for the kind of
initial data or
three
yeah great question so the question is
um doesn't this mean that we're going to
have less data for parts of the state
space or parts of the kind of action
distributions that are less good and
um the the third answer is yes so we'll
we'll have less data in those regions
um the good news is that
even though you'll have less data and
your model will be less accurate in
those regions
um
the if it then thinks that some of those
action sequences are good because like
erroneously thinks that they're going to
be good then it will eventually
kind of optimize for reward pick those
actions and then collect data and it's
essentially going to be self-correcting
where whenever it erroneously thinks
something is good then it will collect
data in that region and
um and then ultimately learn that it's
not good
um and if there's any parts of the state
space that you don't have a lot of data
in but think are bad
um then it will choose not to visit that
those parts of the state space
cool
um so
this is kind of the
the kind of complete version one of
model based Ro where you fit a model to
some data you plan using that model and
then you add that data to your buffer
now
um the last version I'd like to talk
about is uh trying to do a little bit
better than this and this is getting
back to the question of open loop versus
closed loop
so one of the things that you might have
noticed
um is that
right now we are planning a sequence of
actions and then executing those actions
in the environment
and what this ends up looking like is if
you
have your agent
um
and you have your world then what it's
going to do is it's going to kind of
execute
the actions that it optimized
and in order to kind of try to
accomplish
the task
and this is what's referred to
as open loop
and there's a kind of alternative
Paradigm where you're actually going to
try to close this Loop where
at each time step
instead of just passing in or kind of
taking the sequence of actions and
running them you're going to take
one action
and then
see what the next state is
and then use that next state to
determine your next action
and so this is what's referred to as
closed loop uh
hopefully for reasons that are clear
because we see a loop there
now
does anyone have thoughts on when open
loop might be a bad idea
yeah so if your environment is
stochastic then
this open loop
uh version is going to be sub-optimal
most likely and the reason for that is
that if you don't know what your next
state is
then if there's basically stochasticity
in your Dynamics
then if you base your actions on your
most recent State then you'll be able to
account for the what happens and the
stochasticity and the Dynamics whereas
in this case you you don't have any way
to account for the fact that like St
plus 1 or St plus 2 might be different
from kind of the the average case
cool
um so then does anyone have thoughts on
how we might accomplish this closed loop
approach with in model based role yeah
absolutely
of course
yeah exactly so
the in both cases we are going to be
trying to look ahead and like predict
what's going to happen in the future
um the key difference is that if we're
uncertain about what's going to happen
then we need to in this case we need a
plan with respect to like that
uncertainty we need to
plan under lots of different possible
circumstances that might happen and then
just kind of execute an action sequence
that seems reasonable with according to
those predictions where in this case we
essentially get a look at the next state
and
um kind of decide what actions to take
again based off of the state that we saw
the state
sequence that you think you're going to
get based on that action sequence and
then the state sequence that you
actually do and then we try to stay
paranoid maps to try to stay close
thank you
yeah so that's that's an interesting
idea so one thing that you could
essentially try to do if I'm
understanding correctly is to
try to
um
basically try to choose actions so that
you are staying in a part of the space
that is fairly predictable
um and so if you're trying to
essentially match the trajectories
between what you like what you think and
what actually happens then you're
essentially going to try to try to stay
in parts of the space where the Dynamics
are more deterministic
um and in that case actually an open
loop plan might work a lot better
because it's going to
be if there are parts of the state space
that are more deterministic then you can
try to solve the task by staying in
those parts of the state space
does that is that kind of what you were
thinking
cool
um that's actually
a pretty cool thing is not
actually.common to do that because
estimating how deterministic things are
is a little bit difficult but there are
some more advanced techniques that do
something like that
um that are pretty cool
um
and then in terms of like how to so that
something like that would still be
somewhat open loop in terms of how we
could
learn how we could kind of move towards
the second Paradigm here what we can do
is instead of planning a sequence of
actions at the first time step and
rolling them out
what we can do is we can plan it the
first time step optimize for a sequence
of actions take only the first action in
that sequence
and then observe what the next state is
and then once you observe the next state
you can replan and rerun your
optimization to again pick an action
sequence from that new state
um
and the sort of replanning approach can
essentially account for the Dynamics in
the environment especially stochastic
Dynamics it may be a little bit
expensive because you're going to be
running this planning stuff at every
single time step potentially but one
thing that you could do is you could
potentially warm start the optimization
from the plan that you had at the
previous time set
um and so in terms of how this works
um this is essentially what's referred
to as model predictive control or MPC
which is maybe a bit of a fancy name but
essentially what it is is you run some
initial policy you learn a model from
that policy you use that model to
optimize for your sequence of actions
then instead of executing all of the
actions you execute only the first
planned action
and observe the resulting state
um and then you kind of go back to
optimizing your action sequence from
there
I'm also kind of append this to the data
set but we're going to
um
have essentially these two Loops one
Loop is this this inner loop is the
closed loop process where we're going to
be kind of replanting it every single
time step and this outer loop is going
to be the process of adding data to your
buffer and refitting your model
underneath
yeah so the question is um shouldn't our
model f also be stochastic uh
so if your Dynamics are stochastic you
should also uh try to fit a model that's
stochastic um in the slides for
Simplicity I was denoting it as uh kind
of just using mean squared error in a
deterministic model
um one of the things that's cool about
the sampling based approach is with even
if you have a stochastic model you don't
have to change anything about this
optimization with gradient-based
approaches
um you could also choose to uh I guess
it depends on how you implement your
model but it's not too difficult to
optimize through that
depending on on some of the details
in that case you'd be fitting a Model F
that is like modeling the distribution
over
over S Prime rather than just outputting
a deterministic estimate for S Prime
and then the way this works is if you
kind of accidentally make a mistake at
one time step and notice that you made
that mistake then you can actually
essentially correct for that error that
you made
or correct for some aspect of the
Dynamics that were unpredictable
all right
cool um so this can correct for model
errors it is more compute intensive
because we are trying to run things
um run the sort of planning at every
single time step in particular it's
compute intensive at test time rather
than a training time
um but there are ways to try to like
warm start the optimization to alleviate
that challenge
Okay so
what does this all have to do with
multitask RL
um like I mentioned before there are
these
there are two cases with respect to the
reward function in one case
um maybe you know the form of the reward
function exactly so maybe you know maybe
you can observe the positions of objects
and your goal is to like get the
position the object position to be in a
certain position
um then what you could do is learn a
single model and then plan with respect
to each of your award functions at test
time
and so at test time if you're given if
you're told that you should do task one
then you can plan with respect to the
reward for task one and likewise for the
other tasks
um so as an example for this uh
RI might correspond to trying to
accomplish some different pencil
trajectories by essentially writing
different characters
and uh what this approach is doing is it
is uh it's running planning with respect
to a model that it learned to try to
write these different trajectories and
sorry write these different digits so
for example the second one is a seven
the third one is a four I think the last
one might be a five
um
so uh yeah RI corresponds to these
different trajectories and we can just
once we have our model we can plan to
accomplish all these different
trajectories at test time
as another example
um our I could also correspond to
different introductories or positions of
a ball held in the hand
and so uh for example here you see these
little red dots that are spinning and
this is showing the desired trajectory
of the two balls in the hand and it's
running planning with respect to a
learned model in order to spin the balls
in its hand
um and also you can give it for example
different goal positions of a single
ball and it can also figure out how to
move its hand in a way that will hit
that Target position
um and here's another example I think in
this case it's uh going clockwise
instead of counterclockwise
cool
um
then one last caveat that I'll mention
is that uh in the multitask scenario
if you are iteratively collecting data
uh the reward is going to change what
data you collect
and so you will want to
um
at during training you're going to want
to have different reward functions or in
order to collect in order to cover the
distribution of tasks in terms of the
data that you collect
cool and then one other thing that's
pretty cool is uh model based role tends
to be fairly sample efficient
um and this means that you can actually
run the same approach on a real robot
and this is a five-finger shadow hand
that is kind of twirling these two balls
with exactly the approach that we talked
about before where it's learning a
Dynamics model from a couple hours of
data on the robot and then running
planning with respect to
um with respect to this trajectory-like
goal at test time
cool
um so that was the case where we knew
the reward function as a function of the
state and in particular we knew the
positions of the objects and then we
just measured the reward function as
like the distance or the negative
distance between the object position and
the goal position
um in other cases we might not know the
reward function directly
and
um
there's a few different ways that we can
do do this we can try to learn a reward
function with supervised learning
and use that learned reward function in
addition to the learn model in order to
plan
um another thing that we could do is we
could also meta learn a reward function
where we're given a few examples of
success and failure for a reward
function and we want to kind of adapt
over word function based on that data
and so an example of doing this is
um you can give it if you do some sort
of metal learning approach for learning
a success classifier you can give it
some positive examples of success so in
this case the goal is to put the the
pencil case behind the notebook and the
robot is just looking at the images here
the state space is just images
and um we'll use this to acquire a
reward function for this particular task
where it's going it should assign kind
of a positive value for when it's behind
the notebook and a negative value when
it's not
and then once we have this binary reward
function we can use it for planning
um so we'll learn a model and then plan
with respect to that model to try to
accomplish the goal and push the the
pencil case to be behind the notebook
um
cool and this allows you to both solve
multitask RL as well as the meta RL
problem statement
depending on the kind of supervision
that you have
cool any questions on on this before we
move on
cool so
um next we'll talk about model based RL
with image observations or just
generally when you have very high
dimensional inputs
um and this is a scenario that uh
I think actually comes up a fair amount
oftentimes you can't like directly
observe some really nice low dimensional
state
and
um so for example say you want the robot
to uh be able to use the spatula to lift
the the white object into the bowl
um in this case like in general the
robot can access camera images
it can't access the position of the
objects directly
and we'd like to be able to
um
yeah we like to be able to solve this
task with model based RL with only
access to images
um also it's difficult to define a
reward function with only observations
one thing that we could do is learn the
classifier like we talked about before
um but in other cases maybe uh
we might not want to learn a classifier
because maybe it would take a fair
amount of supervision
um so for the reward signal one option
is to learn a classifier another option
is just to try to provide an image of
the goal of what you want the robot to
solve and then this essentially
corresponds to goal condition Daryl so
you could give it an image that looks
like this and say I want you to try to
reach this image
um
and you could use this to try to derive
some reward function that tries to match
images for example
okay um so in terms of approaches for
this problem setting there's three
causes of approaches One Is to learn a
latent space and learn a little model in
that latent space
the second is to learn a model directly
on observations and the third is to try
to predict alternative quantities rather
than predicting uh future States
um so first let's talk about learning
models in latent space
so really the key idea here is instead
of trying to model in the original image
space we want to learn a lower
dimensional representation of images
and then learn a model in that lower
dimensional space
so for example if you have
um
a graphical model that looks like this
where your observations are being
observed but you can't observe your low
dimensional States
then what you could try to do is learn
model G that can estimate your latent
States from your observation
um and so the key idea is to essentially
just try to learn this
latent encoder G
and then once you
get this latent dimensional State space
then you can just do model based RL in
that space
um there are a couple different
approaches that I've looked at a problem
like this uh and we'll go over
essentially these these two approaches
the
really the key challenge is actually how
do you do this first step of learning
the latent like the the low dimensional
latent State space
okay so
um in terms of the high level sketch of
the algorithm first we'll collect some
data then we're going to learn the
embedding of your observations
as well as a model in that latent space
and then we'll use this model to
optimize for actions
and then we can execute the actions
and and potentially iterate this process
so this is the same algorithm as before
it's just the first step of uh the first
part of step two has changed to also
learn this late in embedding space
um now what is the reward function for
optimizing actions uh one thing that we
can do is if we have an image of the
goal we can use the negative distance
between the embedding of the goal and
the embedding of your current
observation
and this can give you a reward signal
that assumes that distance in your
latent space is a reasonable metric for
measuring uh
measuring distances between states
cool now the key question is then how do
you optimize this latent embedding
uh
one approach um I don't want to go into
too much detail here but one approach is
to essentially learn something that
looks like a lot like a variational
autoencoder
uh to learn a latent space and uh in
particular you'll try to learn a latent
space that can reconstruct your images
um this approach is slightly more
sophisticated than that instead of just
learning a vae for a single time step
it's also going to jointly learn that
with a Dynamics model in your latent
space
and this should produce the latent space
that not only captures information about
the image but also allows you to learn
how to predict in that space
um and this makes sense because if you
only learned an autoencoder and then
tried to predict it could be that the
latent space is organized in a way
that's difficult to predict the next
state from the current state
cool um and so uh
kind of an example of what this does you
can give it a goal state of reaching a
particular
um a particular image shown here and
then once you have your latent state
space you can run planning
in that space to try to learn how to
reach that goal
and so the left is showing the image
from actually rolling out the planning
process and here's another goal State
and then the right is showing
um
the right is showing the generated
predictions from
facing forward one step and then
reconstructing the frame by passing it
through the decoder of the auto encoder
um
one thing that's cool about this
approach is that it's quite efficient
even though it's trying to learn skills
directly from Pixel observations here
and so
um
it was learned this Behavior with just
about 300 trials which would correspond
to probably about 25 minutes of real
time
uh
and it's also able to to solve multiple
different goals rather than just a
single goal
cool um and then there's one more
example uh
instead of trying to use an autoencoder
I guess it's still going to be using an
auto encoder but instead of trying to
um
just like kind of only give it the
structure of predicting the next state
we can also impose some sort of
regularization on our latent State as
well
and in particular
um in an example like robotics we might
want our latent State space to
correspond to positions of objects
and if we want to do that what we can do
is we can pass our image through an
encoder and then constrain our latent
space to correspond to 2D feature points
in the image
and the way this can work is that you
take your last convolutional map
then you take a soft Max over the
spatial dimension of that map so then
you're going to get a probability
distribution for each channel of your
um each channel of your Con 3 map
and then once you get this distribution
over 2D positions
then you can essentially take an
expectation
which will
take the expected x y coordinate or
expected i j coordinate which looks
something like this
which will take that distribution over
2D positions and give you a single point
out it's going to essentially give you
the um the mean X Y position
for that particular distribution
you can essentially think of this as a
spatial attention
uh where it's essentially attending to
the part of the feature map that has
high activations
um and the results of this is that
you'll get east east two dimensions of
your latent space are going to
correspond to a 2d coordinate in your
image
and you can then actually overlay those
2D coordinates back on the image itself
and here are two examples of of feature
points that this kind of Auto encoder
will give you
um and you can see that this is
visualizing the feature point over time
and you can see that one of them is
tracking the finger of the gripper and
the other one is tracking the uh the
object
um cool and so essentially the embedding
here is much more structured than if you
were to just have a more unconstrained
autoencoder
cool and then if you use a blatant space
like this and run model based RL with
this latent space
um
this is what the kind of learning
process looks like it was initialized
with the policy that generally knows how
to move its arm to the right position
but not the object and then over time
it's learning
um learning to improve its model and
learning how to eventually get a
behavior that can successfully push the
block over to the left this was given a
goal image of
um of pushing it to a particular
position
and then in terms of the final policy it
looks something like this where it's
able to push it uh
to kind of about the correct position on
this uh
on this mat
and then if we go back to the task that
we wanted to do before where we needed
to lift the object uh and place it into
the bowl I can also use this sort of
model based RL approach in the latent
space in order to solve the task
and then lastly you can also visualize
the feature points on top of the image
which is kind of cool and see what kinds
of representations it's learning and we
see that in each of these cases it
typically learns at least one feature
point that tracks the relevant object
and other feature points that track the
arm or track other parts of the scene
um cool and so this was looking at three
different tasks
um and for each of these tasks it was uh
learned using about 11 minutes of robot
time so this is again emphasizing that
model based RL approaches are pretty
efficient
um yeah and the caveat here is that the
representation was actually learned also
in a fairly environment specific way
cool um so that was one approach which
is to try to learn a latent space that
um and then run planning in that latent
space
now in both approaches we're learning
this latent Space by reconstructing the
image
and the first approach reconstructed the
image and also learned a Dynamics model
in that latent space
now a thought exercise for you is
um why do we need to reconstruct the
image
and in particular could we learn
an embedding space
learner representation space and the
encoder for that representation such
that you're able to predict the next
representation of that encoder
um any thoughts on on whether we could
do something like this
and to be clear the kind of the
objective would be that we have um
we have some encoder G that tells us
that encodes
um our observation and we're going to be
trying to kind of optimize for the
parameters of G with respect to
um
the ability to predict
s t plus one
so we're learning I guess this would be
with both with respect to G and with
respect to f
does anyone have any thoughts on whether
you could do something like this
yeah
um
foreign
yeah so by when you also include an
objective that tries to reconstruct the
observation you're essentially you're
saying that we were regularizing the
embedding to separate out different
observations
yeah any additional thoughts on that
any thoughts on I guess what do you
think would happen if um like what what
G would you get if you optimized this
objective
yeah so what could happen is if you
optimize the subjective the
representation could just collapse
because what it could do is it could
learn to map G for example
G could just learn to always output zero
and if you always output zero
then
you can perfectly like predict the
subjective because it's always zero
right um or me or it could I mean it
doesn't have to be zero it could always
output like five or something and then
this model just knows that I should
always output five
and then you get zero loss here and
life is good in terms of this objective
uh but life is not good in terms of
actually
um being able to use this embetting for
performing tasks
does that make sense
cool so kind of the takeaway here is
that we can't just try to optimize for
predictability in some latent space we
also need that
um that latent space to
reconstruct parts of the
um of the observation are somehow it
needs to be told that it needs to encode
information about the observation
because this objective isn't um it's
there's nothing in this objective that
tells it that s needs to encode anything
about oh
cool
um so the benefits of these approaches
that learn in the latent States is that
they are able to learn pretty complex
skills fairly efficiently if you use a
structured representation space then
this enables pretty effective learning
um the downsizer that the reconstructive
objections the Reconstruction objectives
might not recover the right
representation
and
we kind of talked about before how
there's a question that came up that
like if your state has a lot of stuff in
it that isn't relevant to the task then
the model might choose not to model the
stuff that's relevant to the task and as
kind of an explicit illustration of this
um at one point when I was running some
of the experiments for the previous
paper I wanted to get the robot to
um essentially like like toss a ping
pong ball and this is an example uh like
grayscale low-dimensional image of from
the robot's camera
uh you can see the ping pong ball in
white
and then I tried to train an auto
encoder on this data
and what I got was a reconstruction that
looks like this
and essentially what you see is that the
auto encoder is just deciding to ignore
the ping pong ball because it was kind
of hard to reconstruct it's also also
only a small part of the image and it
doesn't really get
um that much of a loss incurred by
essentially erasing the ping pong ball
um and so this means that sometimes
these approaches if there's a large part
of the image a large part of the
observation that isn't relevant to the
task and a small part that is relevant
to the task it might choose not to
represent the things that are highly
relevant to the task
Um this can be a big downside and so
essentially we need better
um representation learning methods
ideally unsupervised representation
learning methods in order to
solve this kind of problem
cool um and then it's also worth
mentioning that these like using low
dimensional embeddings can also be
useful for model free approaches not
just for model based approaches
um there's this uh older work from 2012
that learns the latent space and does
fitted Q iteration which is essentially
a variant on Q learning in that latent
space
um there's also you can also do trpo
which is a policy gradient method in a
latent space on a real robot and it ends
up being much more efficient than if you
were to do it on the original space
um low dimensional vettings can also be
useful for computing rewards so
uh some Works have essentially used a
video representation
um and use an encoding of that
representation using something like
image that features in order to measure
the reward for the task of opening a
door and then you can train a robot to
optimize that objective and it can learn
to open a different door for example
um using a reward function in that
latent space
um great and then also if you have
reward function labels then you could
also use it to form up even better
latent space as well a lot of the work
that we talked about before we're trying
to learn these latent States in a more
unsupervised way but in cases where you
do have some supervision you can use
that and leverage it to for example pay
attention to the ping pong ball
um
and encourage it to do that
great
um
so
the previous class of methods was trying
to learn a latent space and learn a
model in that space
you can also actually just learn a model
in the original observation space as
well
so essentially if you take the MPC
algorithm
um you can essentially just replace all
the s's with O's
and uh
just do the same thing as before
in this case the model needs to directly
operate on o and so this means that
you'll need to learn a fairly complex
model in order to for example predict
video into the future
um and so as kind of one is concrete
instantiation of this we could run a
random policy to collect some data like
data that looks like this
then learn a model to try to predict
what the future will look like
you can get a model that essentially can
predict different features different
videos into the future based off of the
actions that the robot takes
um
one of the things that's cool about
operating on images is that you can also
apply these images these models to
things like deformable objects like
towels it's pretty difficult to think
about how to represent the state of the
world if it involves a towel but if you
can operate directly on images then or
learn a latent representation then that
allows you to manipulate the horrible
objects
and then once you have this this video
prediction model you can use it to
optimize for Action sequences
um as a couple details here uh
in terms of how to predict video
um
some of the kind of best approaches
right now we'll use a deep recurrent
neural network they'll try to predict
multiple frames into the future and
they'll condition that Network on
actions so that it's actually
incorporating the robot's actions into
its prediction of the future and
oftentimes these models are stochastic
in order to try to capture the
uncertainty about what future images
will look like
and then
yeah
um I'll talk about that in like the
slide after this one yeah
um so in terms of predicting video
um one other thing that I'll mention for
predicting video is that uh one thing
that's pretty cool is if you scale up
these models uh to be larger you can
actually get pretty good predictions so
these are predictions on a deformable
object data set and you can see that
the predictions which are shown on the
left are actually I mean in this case
maybe even indistinguishable from the
the ground truth
um and this means that you can if you
can get very good predictions then you
should be able to plan very well with
this model
um
I'll talk about how to plan and then
I'll talk about how to get rewards so
um for how to plan we can do the same
sort of sampling based optimization that
we talked about before
um so as an example for like random
shooting this would look like sampling a
bunch of different action sequences such
as these two actions
then producing the feature for those
actions and so you can run those actions
through your video production model to
predict different futures
and then pick the feature that you like
the best
and execute the corresponding action
and then you can repeat kind of the
steps one through three to replan uh
like we talked about before
um so simply this is just uh this MPC
approach that we talked about before but
in visual space or visual MPC
um cool actually I don't actually have a
slide on on getting rewards but there's
a few different approaches that you can
use
um One Is to learn a classifier
so if you learn a class an image
classifier that tells you if the future
is good or not then you can when you're
kind of looking evaluating your futures
you can run those predicted images
through your image classifier and it
will tell you if the feature is good or
the future is bad your classifier will
need to generalize to predictions from
the video production model and so if
they're blurry for example you'll need
to account for that
um another thing that you could do is
you could give it a goal image and if
you give it a goal image then you can
just look at like LT distance or
distance in some space between their
predicted image and that goal image
um one last thing that you can do that's
a little bit more complex is I you can
tell it where you want objects to move
in the image
um like tell it like I want this like
this pixel to move over here for example
and there are some video prediction
models that implicitly
predict how pixels are going to move in
the image and for those kinds of models
you can actually essentially use their
flow predictions to evaluate whether or
not it's accomplishing a certain goal
cool so um as an example of that last
approach you could say I want you to
move this red pixel up to the to the top
left
um this would correspond to a task
that's kind of roughly along the lines
of folding
um folding the short
then you can run planning with respect
to that goal and it's going to give you
it's going to say that this prediction
looks pretty good in terms of
accomplishing the subjective
and then you'll run
um you run these actions on the robot
and uh you'll get
behavior that looks something like this
now one of the things that's cool about
this is that you could actually use a
single model not just to solve this one
task but lots of different tasks
so
um you can give it a goal of picking up
the the stuffed animal on the left
you can give it a goal of moving the
sleeve of the shirt over to the right
putting an apple on a plate
and essentially it's going to use its
model to plan to accomplish these
different goals at test time I mean you
don't even need to tell it these tasks
during training
yeah
yeah
so the question is is there a reason why
the robot is moving in discrete steps
um the I guess there's a few different
ways to actually do robot control one is
in a more like a very synchronous
fashion where you move and then you pick
an action and then you move again and
you pick an action you could also do it
asynchronously
um
one of the things that's uh I guess if
you're replanning at every time step
um that planning time might take some
computation time
um and the
uh
I guess there's a few few things here
but one is that if you want to replant
every time step for that current image
then it's easiest to do things
synchronously
um it's you can in principle do it
asynchronously but it gets uh more
complicated
and you also need a control for the
frequency at which you collected the
data and the frequency that you're
actually rolling out the actions at test
time
because you don't want to have a
mismatch in your control frequency
because then you'll have like a mismatch
in the data distribution
um and here are kind of a few more
examples of tasks
um including the last example of like
uh folding a towel over an object
cool
um so in terms of modeling directly in
observation space
um one thing that's pretty nice about
this is
um I guess in comparison to some of the
other approaches this is operating on
real images
it also requires pretty little human
involvement
um
the train is video production model is
like fully self-supervised on your data
and you can also accomplish a lot of
different tasks with a single model
the downside is that
um if you have a lot of background
variability it's going to be much harder
to learn a good model
and this kind of planning approach here
can't handle as complex skills as as
other methods because it's just using
like a random shooting planner and uh
yeah more sophisticated planners and so
forth can accomplish more
um
more challenging skills also uh because
the model is so large you can't roll out
that many samples uh unless you have a
ton of compute basically so it's fairly
compute intensive it has time
okay um and the last thing I'd like to
mention is that I instead of predicting
future States or future observations
um in some cases you can also predict
other quantities
and there's a few different kind of
instantiations of this so if you want to
learn how to grasp you could try to
predict like
if I take these actions will my grasp be
successful
or if I take a sequence of actions will
I Collide into something or if I take a
sequence of actions like what were my
help what my health be what will my
damage be and so forth
um you can essentially think of this as
a different variant of model based Earl
whereas instead of predicting
the state into the future you're
predicting some statistics about that
state
um and then you can use the same kinds
of planning approaches with these
predictive models
um this also has a fairly close
connection to key learning so if you
think about the reward being the
probability of some event happening then
these kinds of approaches are producing
the probabilities of events and so
in that case they're uh
essentially predicting future reward and
few functions are predicting future
reward as well
um so the upside of this approach is
that you're potentially only predicting
these task relevant quantities and this
can be quite helpful quite useful when
you have very like complex observation
spaces
uh the downside is that you need to have
you need to be able to observe those
quantities you need to have labels of
those quantities in your data
um and you of course you need to pick
the qualities somewhat manually
great um so to wrap up we talked about
model based RL in this lecture and we
also talked about model free learning
previously and so I'd like to illustrate
some of the pros and cons of these
approaches
for models it's pretty easy to collect
data in a self-supervised way and train
the model in the self-supervised way
um these models are very transferable
across different reward functions
and typically they require a smaller
quantity of reward supervised data
because you're offloading a lot of the
effort onto learning the model rather
than learning a model of reward
um the downside is that these models are
optimizing for being able to predict the
future and not for task performance
and sometimes it's harder to learn a
model than it is to learn a policy
um and then lastly it you sometimes need
assumptions in order to learn more
complex skills because uh the models for
those more complex skills might also be
fairly complex
um in the model free case uh it makes
very little assumptions
um
with regard to like the complexity of
your observation space the complexity of
your Dynamics and so forth and it's
fairly effective for learning complex
policies
the downside is that it ends up
requiring more experience typically and
it's also a a harder optimization
problem in the multitask setting because
you have to learn kind of multiple Cube
like you're popular like a multitask
queue function or a multitask policy
um ultimately I think that we in many
scenarios probably want elements of both
if we can learn a good model then we
should use that
um
but it would also be nice to have some
of the kind of pros of model free
methods
great
um so that concludes the main content
for today
um for next time uh we've talked about
multitask girl so far and so next week
on Monday and Wednesday we'll talk about
meta reinforcement learning and then as
a couple of reminders the mid quarter
survey is out and uh homework free is
out as well